foreign
some people call it gender transition
surgery what it really is it's
life-changing altering sterilization
surgeries and that's wrong for a minor
we have a duty to protect minors from a
lot of things we don't let them drink we
don't let them get tattoos their brains
aren't fully developed and so when I
found out that we were
life-altering surgeries on a healthy
children
Oklahomans overwhelmingly support me
that just says hey this is not something
we're going to allow to be done to
minors and use taxpayer dollars if
you're you know we're not against
anybody but if you're an adult and
you're making a decision for a some kind
of cosmetic surgery or some kind of
surgery that you that you want to
perform and you're paying for it okay
that's great but we're not going to
allow that to happen to minors puberty
blockers do affect people right they're
saying oh it's just pausing that's not
true your frontal lobe's not developed
that is affecting you
[Music]
when the government has gets itself
involved in all these things trying to
fund all these different things
taxpayers get frustrated right we don't
want to fund we don't believe in bigger
government we don't want to fund things
that don't make sense to us but all of a
sudden the left is piling on saying oh
this is perfectly fine let's let a minor
self-diagnose themselves 12 years old
and then we'll order the doctor of what
procedure to do again we're not going to
let it happen in Oklahoma I think every
state should be looking at it finding
out making sure it's not happening in
their state and again this isn't against
any one person or any class of people
this is just something that doesn't make
sense to do to minors let's make sure
that they're healthy that they're fully
developed that they are adults and then
they can make that decision We Believe
In traditional family values in Oklahoma
and to think about minors healthy
children being permanently altered
either through hormone therapy or some
kind of surgery it's not going to happen
in Oklahoma as long as I'm Governor I
overwhelmingly have the support of
Oklahomans on this issue and again it's
not against any one class or any one
person but let's wait to your mind is
fully developed and you're choosing
something as an adult and we're not
going to let that happen to children
[Music]